TONY?
>> SHOWS HOW RARE THIS REALLY
IS.
OMAR, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> THE DEFENSE IS EXPECTED TO
REST ITS CASE TODAY IN THE TRIAL
OF FORMER POLICE OFFICER DEREK
CHAUVIN.
A RETIRED FORENSIC PATHOLOGIST
WAS THE ONLY WITNESS TO TESTIFY
WEDNESDAY, AND HE FACED INTENSE
SCRUTINY FROM THE PROSECUTION.
JAMIE YUCCAS WAS THERE IN COURT
YESTERDAY AS A POOL REPORTER.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING, TONY.
DR. DAVID FOWLER TESTIFIED THAT
GEORGE FLOYD HAD MANY FACTORS
THAT COULD HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO
HIS DEATH.
THAT TESTIMONY DIRECTLY
COUNTERED THE PROSECUTION'S
ARGUMENT THAT FLOYD COULDN'T
BREATHE BECAUSE HE WAS PINNED
UNDER CHAUVIN'S KNEE.
I CAN TELL YOU FROM BEING INSIDE
THE COURTROOM MUCH OF THE JURY
IS PAYING ATTENTION TO IT ALL.
DEFENSE EXPERT WITNESS DR. DAVID
FOWLER TESTIFIED IT WAS HIS
OPINION THE CAUSE OF DEATH
SHOULD BE UNDETERMINED BECAUSE
THERE WERE SO MANY POTENTIAL
REASONS GEORGE FLOYD DIED,
INCLUDING HEART DISEASE, DRUG
USE, AND THEN ONE THE JURY
HADN'T HEARD BEFORE --
>> THERE IS EXPOSURE TO A
VEHICLE EXHAUST.
SO POTENTIALLY CARBON MONOXIDE
POISONING.
>> Reporter: FOWLER SAID IT WAS
A POSSIBILITY BECAUSE FLOYD WAS
RESTRAINED CLOSE TO THE POLICE
CAR'S EXHAUST PIPES.
THE PROSECUTION FOUGHT BACK.
>> DO YOU AGREE WITH ME THAT
THERE WAS NO FINDING OF CARBON
MONOXIDE POISONING FROM DR.
BAKER'S AUTOPSY REPORT?
>> I DO.
>> DO YOU KNOW IF, IN FACT, THE
CAR WAS ON OR NOT?
YOU DIDN'T SEE ANY INFORMATION
OR DATA FROM ANYBODY WHO SAYS I
EITHER TURNED THE CAR ON OR I'M
THE ONE WHO TURNED IT OFF?
>> CORRECT.
>> Reporter: FOWLER EMPHASIZED
FLOYD'S DRUG USE AS A POTENTIAL
CAUSE OF DEATH.
>> IN THE BACK CORNER OF MR.
FLOYD'S MOUTH, YOU CAN SEE WHAT
APPEARS TO BE A WHITE OBJECT.
>> Reporter: ON
CROSS-EXAMINATION, PROSECUTOR
JERRY BLACKWELL WENT BACK TO
WHAT IS IN THE AUTOPSY AREN'T.
>> ISN'T IT TRUE THERE WERE NO
PILLS IN HIS STOMACH?
>> CORRECT, NO PILL, DAB LET.
>> Reporter: THE PROSECUTOR
ASKED DR. FOWLER IF HE AGREED
FLOYD SHOULD HAVE BEEN GIVEN
MEDICAL ATTENTION WHILE HE WAS
ON THE GROUND.
>> IMMEDIATE MEDICAL ATTENTION
FOR A PERSON WHO'S GONE INTO
CARDIAC ARREST MAY WELL REVERSE
THAT PROCESS, YES.
>> Reporter: FOWLER IS CURRENTLY
THE SUBJECT OF A FEDERAL LAWSUIT
IN MARYLAND BROUGHT BY ANTON
BLACK'S FAMILY WHO CLAIMS HE AND
THE MEDICAL EXAMINER'S OFFICE
COVERED UP POLICE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THEIR 19-YEAR-OLD SON'S
DEATH.
THE YOUNG MAN DIED WHILE BEING
SUBDUED BY POLICE IN 2018.
THE JUDGE RULED THE PROSECUTION
COULD BRING REBUTTAL WITNESSES
STARTING TODAY.
TONY?
>> JAMIE, AS WE MENTIONED AT THE
TOP, YOU WERE ONE OF ONLY TWO
POOL REPORTERS WHICH MEANS YOU
WERE ALLOWED IN THE COURTROOM
YESTERDAY.
WHAT WAS YOUR TAKEAWAY BEING IN
THE ROOM FOR FIRST TIME?
>> Reporter: YEAH, TONY, I HAVE
TO TELL YOU THERE'S A LOT OF
NERVOUS ENERGY BETWEEN THE
PROSECUTION AND THE DEFENSE WHEN
YOU'RE SITTING THERE.
THE JURORS ARE OFTEN TAKING LOTS
OF NOTES.
BUT HALFWAY THROUGH THE THIRD
WEEK OF THIS TRIAL, YOU CAN SEE
THE TOLL IT'S STARTING TO TAKE,
ESPECIALLY WITH SUCH COMPLEX
TESTIMONY LIKE WE SAW YESTERDAY.
I DO WANT TO POINT OUT AS FOR
DEREK CHAUVIN, HE HAS REPEATEDLY
BEEN DESCRIBED IN COURT AS 140
POUNDS.
WHEN I SAW HIM FROM LESS THAN
TEN FEET AWAY, IT STRUCK ME HOW
SMALL HE REALLY IS IN STATURE.
HE ALSO IS CONSTANTLY WRITING
NOTES HIMSELF, IN ALMOST
MECHANICAL FASHION.
TONY?
>> INTERESTING DETAILS THERE AND
NOTABLE TO HEAR THAT THE JURY IS